as pessoas no geral têm dificuldade de
entender o que eu faço
normalmente quando me perguntam quero
resposta rápida eu respondo que o
problema do uso de cabos
afinal guitarra e aguenta o cara fez um
show inteiro é mais um pouco mais que
isso
eu na verdade sou um técnico que está
rodando inglês ea tradução livre
vittek muito comumente confundido com
road ou do inglês road que na verdade é
qualquer pessoa que viaja com a banda
vai desde o motorista do caminhão até um
iluminador somos todos holdings e
cuidando de guitarra que que é cuidar de
guitarra um prolongamento de cabo
afinal instrumento aguenta cara fez um
show inteiro e para as pessoas com quem
eu trabalho normalmente ela só chega no
palco para tocar num primeiro momento
que elas vêem o instrumento
eu entrego ela pega e começa o show que
vocês assistem
então é imprescindível que tem uma
pessoa que consegue entender exatamente
o que ela precisa pra ela poder fazer
essa performance analogia que eu gosto
de fazer com o carro de fórmula 1 eu
monto deixa funcionando fácil correr na
pista como máximo que eu posso mas
enquanto airton sena não entra ali me
disse que o catar fugir de traseira na
terceira curva eu não consigo deixar
perfeito entrosamento é imprescindível
que a gente consiga se comunicar e se
entender e às vezes o entrosamento não é
feito com linguagem que a gente entenda
normalmente eu escuto coisas do tipo
santa marrom cinza marrom resolve
tá muito tá muito tridente isso não em
que se quer é bem enfim faz parte do meu
trabalho além do fim na guitarra pra
mesa de casa e aguenta cara feia
eu tenho um amigo meu que recentemente
perguntou se eu conseguir ver o som
deixa pergunta engraçada lógico e pensei
um pouco e sim eu consigo ver o som
na realidade eu consigo escutar uma
música identificar guitarra e pensar em
caminhos para chegar àquele som eu
consigo que você me diga qual é o
momento que você tem
eu saber que campos o nós estamos
trabalhando que vai soar dali se eu
fosse um ex man provavelmente seria meu
poder ver o som eu tenho vou chamar isso
de privilégio de trabalhar com artistas
que eu considero as incríveis ponto de
vista técnico ponto de vista artístico
uns mais que outros lógico os me
agradado mais que outro mas poderá
contar quatro histórias bem rápido
parece que num num se comunicam assim se
como único
uma é falado no santos ele tem um bom
time o hábito de chegar mais cedo no
show e tocar pode acho que é uma
passagem de som normal mas não sei que
também faz chegar lá conversar com os
músicos fazer um arranjo
vamos mudar isso aqui essa introdução na
bolsa ele faz parte do trabalho dele
eu estou dizendo que chegaram antes do
show e com um canto tipo montar um set
para lhe perguntar e ficar tocando tocam
tocam fica curtindo
nunca conversei com ele sobre o assunto
mas o que me passa aquele ali se
divertindo
aquele momento é dele só isso e eu
privilégio meu escutar coisas que tipo
nulo tocando eric clapton hendrix ficar
se você não vê no show toca coisa que
não faço a menor idéia do que seja eu
fico imaginando se uma música nova que
está fazendo mas enfim a imagem que me
passa é que está ali se divertir no
único pavimento
depois ele termina bota roupa e vocês
vêem aquilo que você tem que ver é
xandão do rappa
ele mora em um estúdio em curitiba e o
estúdio dele o jeito dele trabalhar no
sus é muito eu acho muito interessante é
um pouco diferente do que a gente está
acostumado a ver com outras bandas
outros artistas
ele tem um estúdio praticamente vazio
tem uma mesa de gravação dos monitores
mais nada você chega começa a tocar
mostra suas músicas e vai ter uma idéia
da intensidade da chuva montando aqui
monta isso de repente se tem ali eu
gosto de chamar um é um playground um
laboratório playground e um instrumento
que não faço a menor idéia do nome nem
ele sabe também
e muita gente não sabe como tocar aquilo
unicamente para tirar da zona de
conforto que você chega com um violão ao
domínio lançou um expert chegou e vou
tocar e fala para joca acorda olha aqui
hum só que toca aqui no toca você toca
ficou horrível não vai pro disco mas ele
já quebrou tudo que você tinha trazido
de casa e aí você de repente peguei a
viola caipira que também nunca tocou mas
ela parece mais com o violão de repente
a sua ideia sai melhor então é um jeito
que acho interessante que ele faz com
que brote a coisa mais primal mais
animal que a gente tem assim gostem sua
técnica tenham sua musicalidade mas você
sabe aquela zona de conforto eu sei que
estou fazendo não sabe se lá fora eu
tenho um amigo que adora música e não
sabe tocar nenhum instrumento
literalmente não sabe tocar mas ele
adora música já estava na casa de um
outro amigo e começou uma elevação de
som e toca guitarra aqui o tocam
percussão alinhou com baixo ele queria
participar de algum jeito
e aí ele pedir um outro jeito participar
disso ele falou 'não faz o seguinte pega
o baixo de uma visão aqui você fazer as
11 foi só isso mas nada que a gente vai
tocar em volta de você
a música é tão legal tão legal que você
consegue jogar bola
no nível que a pessoa tiver se adapta e
todo mundo já conhece viram a célula
aquilo e odom
dunn e ele foi se empolgando ele fechou
o olho foi se empolgando e o tudo
começou a ver a barba embora o bumbum em
outro ritmo no tom tava horroroso
horrível mas ele foi transportado pela
dimensão que não estava escutando o que
ele estava fazendo com certeza não tinha
parado mas ele não estava lá mas ninguém
teve coragem de falar pra ele para o que
estava se divertindo tanto ele estava se
divertindo tanto que eu vou parar por
aqui pra que a gente fazer um take
perfeito tem ninguém gravando a gente
aqui na casa dos amigos se divertindo e
tem uma coisa que acho engraçado que tem
a cultura do futebol apesar de não jogar
bola não tem nenhum time
eu acho engraçado que você fala assim é
quarta à noite eu vou jogar bola com os
amigos é legal se não faz atividade
física na povoa cana né
eu pego a guitarra bota no umbigo vou
sair alguém pergunta o vizinho tem banda
não tocar com os amigos mas tem banda
não não estou tentando encontrar os
amigos e vai tocar junto à mãe depois
mudar o nome da banda no facebook não
tem banda ka não tem existido tem nome a
gente vai lá não sei o que vai acontecer
você vai ser autoral foi como eu não sei
que vai acontecer a gente vai tocar e e
acorda história que eu queria trazer
rapidamente também
eu não tenho filho macho meus amigos
alguns têm bem pequena e por muitos anos
eu tinha meus instrumentos em casa
guardado violão guitarra essas coisas
não case
dentro do quarto de empregada embaixo
das malas
a coisa mais difícil acesso toda vez que
eu tinha idéias como o autocad dinheiro
longe estica tive lá tira mala bota na
cozinha pego que existe quando montava
um já tinha passado a vontade de volta à
elite é brilhante idéia eu acho
brilhante de botar do lado a televisão
falou hoje na minha casa tem televisão
lembrar aqui tá viola caipira e aqui
está o a guitarra normalmente a plusoft
colar enchendo o saco da minha esposa
primeiro para o licha tem de estar num
lugar mas eu me diverto então pra mim
ronan e nessa coisa que os filhos dos
amigos aparecem lá depois passa aquela
fase a criança fica com vergonha não sei
que elas vão direto um instrumento não
sei qual ela escolhe e começa a bater e
aí o pai sempre falam faz isso que eu
desafinar
eu lembro eu afirmo guitarra muito cara
feito na criança para a mãe deu mole pra
mim é é aí a criança brinca não sei acho
tão bacana assim como não conversei com
o santos com isso as crianças não
conseguem falar comigo então fico
viajando
olha a cara da criança decifre dos meus
amigos e eles olham pra mim o que eu
escuto né falando assim sempre escutando
que estou fazendo
olha só que incrível batendo aqui tá
sendo breve é um breu e eu falo 9 de
maio eu acho o máximo
em algum lugar a gente vai querendo
filtros vai criando barreiras vai se
fechando ficando com vergonha e aquele
instrumento que a gente tinha na sala
ele começa a ver a peça de decoração
daqui a pouco te dá um amigo que a gente
acha que toca melhor vai pro baixo da
mala dentro do quartinho eu aposto muito
de vocês aqui deve ter um instrumento
dessa situação em casa uma flauta gaita
um cooler um violão do amigo um chocalho
aqui feitiço venina suvenir que é um
instrumento gente para tocar a não vai
tocar na televisão mas é legal é
divertido e é isso eu acho que a gente
que a música ela permite esse tipo de
coisa você não precisa ser um músico
você não precisa está vivendo disse isso
aqui é é um milhão
essa cena que vocês vêem outro lado é
que eu não vejo a hora de show
é muito complicado e por muitos anos eu
fui infeliz porque eu achava que o que
eu fazia musicalmente aquela guitarra
tocava em televisão
não fazia sentido porque eu precisava de
um público se eu não trago público para
que estou fazendo mas não é nada disso a
música pra mim como um qualquer arte
uma forma de pressão ela tem que ser uma
coisa e goes to primeiro você se
expressa e se você conseguir outras
pessoas que acreditem naquilo que se
identifiquem com aquilo que você
escreveu o que você cantou com aquela
melodia
quem sabe você consegue likes se você
consegue ginásios lotados e consegue
viver da sua música porque é uma coisa
muito complexa
eu quando fui chamado pra mim que fui
pesquisar o que era a música você
pesquise nos lugares errados mas eu não
consegui achar nenhuma definição para a
música
na verdade não achei várias definições
mas nenhuma delas que falasse música é
isso eu inclusive por exemplo podia
falar vocês música uma energia
estou falando besteira não deixa de ser
porque você escuta a música você sente
aquela vibração e falei que me faz bem
não sei porquê mas a música me fazendo
bem duas coisas que eu cheguei eu li e
achei interessante foi música a ciência
não não é mentira música é uma ciência
tem uma série de regras uma série de
normas uma série de ritmo harmonia
melodia subdivisão até a série de
complexidades que faz ela ser uma
ciência
mas eu sou muito fã de música porque ela
é a ciência é tão bacana tão bacana que
ao contrário da física pelo amor de deus
não estou falando mal da física mas a
física as leis são as leis e acabou a
música qualquer transgressão ela pode
ser bem vinda
você faz uma você comete um erro que não
é um erro aquilo passa a ser um novo
arranjo
a gente tava até brincando aqui antes
qualquer e você fizer ou executando é
dificilmente vocês vão perceber quem
percebe só eu que eu não era isso que
queria fazer mas alguém pode falar até o
músico um professor pode falar nossa mas
que interessante que ele fez ele fez um
intervalo diferente não errei errei feio
se você esperar o próximo reforma vai
ter de novo ela pode e nem sei que eu
fiz mas é isso é tão bonito porque a
operação a ciência ela permite nós
sermos humanos temos orgânicos e
pensando como quiser mas é muito livre
apesar de todas as regras dela
as pessoas me dizem silva não tem o dom
pra isso cai na história da ciência de
novo você não tem um dom
em tese tem gente que nasce gênio não
gostou nada da flauta pedro ii a isso
aqui é um defeito meu deus nunca tocou
não sou gênio nasceu pra isso mas se
você não nasceu pra esse gosta do som da
flauta cento e estuda estuda vai sair
uma hora sai você aí não tendo terminado
vida como uma forma de expressão do ser
que são duas coisas que eu achei que não
era o mais completo sentido né
mas sim a como expressão do ser a música
é uma linguagem que quanto mais
vocabulário você tem melhor você
consegue se comunicar com outras pessoas
e aí eu volto a dizer porque eu sou fã
da música você pode estudar eu conheço
gente que faz isso toda oito horas por
dia todos os dias fica sentado aí para
atacar atacar atacar atacar atacar toca
absurdamente bem só que tem outro da
vitória por mês
você fala um negócio mas do outro é
cruel não é cruel que você está fazendo
pra você pra se divertir civil 8 horas
do dia passando com me divertindo tipo
videogames e quanto mais e toca o melhor
você fica e não quer dizer que as outras
pessoas vão gostar por isso que eu acho
que tem que ser uma coisa boa vista tem
que ser pra você para sua diversão por
seu entretenimento é tendo contato com
essas pessoas esses artistas essas
pessoas eu digo um de coração
é muito difícil eu não vou falar de
brasil não vou falar do mundo você ter
sua seu ganha pão com a arte é muito
difícil
isso é para poucos
há poucos conseguir viver dignamente
então se eu posso pedir uma coisa pra
vocês e deixar um recado é tipo se isso
vier agradece
universo de deus de presente mas se não
veio
faz com amor faz com com vontade para se
divertir que é eu acho que a coisa mais
importante a música pra mim é diversão
obrigado